Họng 2 chăm 5 người mất kể sau đều khánh lươi sật lượng.
Sẵn này ngày 12, kuyến đều khánh lươi xảy ra 3 điểm sật lượng như trọng.
Các viết chi sật cách nhau trường buồn để sau phía lúc mết,
mỗi đoạn khu lượng rất đa sật lượng khoảng 2,5% mới khu ít,
kéo dài hơn 12,5% trong đo sật lượng đều khánh lươi.
Đoạn qua sát xân thái, khiển thành tính làm gió thông chia khác,
3 biệt bẩy xe với khoảng 2 chăm 5 người mất kể ở khu vực này.
Ông phạm ngọc hiểu, chú tịch i bán nhân dân xả xân thái cho biết người bị mất kể trong đoạn có su khác,
người dân để phương cùng nhiều phương thiệt.
Cô vực có lực không có nhà dân, chỉ có một phải nơi có lã nhỏ, biểu.
Để hỗ trận người dân, các quan trích năng vi đọc lượng y bộ qua điểm sật lượng,
vẫn chuyển lượng thực bằng đường bộ, hầu hết người bị kể xức khỏe u立.
Sa đau phối ở gần năng liên qua đầy nháng khắc cuộc sự của sật lượng.
Hẹn khối lượng rất xả xúc đường khá lớn,
biểu khô sọt rất đá chư thiệt khẳng định có thể thóc trứng trong này, ở vữ nói.
Cô lộ 2 bệnh xe dài 1 chăm 2 mốt kêu mết, là tình yên mạnh nối thình của đại là,
lâm đồng với tình của nhà chào khánh hoa.
Chính tuyên có đều khánh lươi dài 3,8 kêu mết thử xin sật lượng vào 1 buồn.